comme hier on voulait partir en vacances
bronzé et les pilules pour bronzer on
les a prises écoutez après huit jours de
traitement
on avait la peau rose mais on a voulu
faire l'expérience jusqu'au bout après
quinze jours on a vu quand même
apparaître une légère pigmentation de la
peau
on sent le truc bidon mais on a insisté
après trois semaines alors là après
trois semaines je dois reconnaître que
geneviève avait bonne mine
oui mais comme je disais entre bonne
mine et bronzage
il ya quand même une drôle de
différentes y ait un mois après mois
je viens donc aujourd'hui
été plus drôle puis amusé en plus de
l'eau
à la fin du deuxième mois tous nos amis
nous ont dit que vous en faut c'est des
collections faux moi qui n'aime pas
lancer je mangeais tout lanco un fou ici
c'est à ce moment là qu'on est parti en
vacances et quand on est arrivé sur la
côte mais que le propriétaire de la
maison qu'on avait loué nous a plu il a
dit c'est déjà loués et partout en
france assez plaisante est situé rue
n'avait pas retrouvé de place vous
simplement qu'on l'appuie du bonhomme et
des blazes à la martinique
et là on a été reçus à bras ouverts
l'ajout vers pâques au bronzage